in this club minute I'm going to show  you how to enable cloud CDN for a  back-end service cloud CDN works as part  of cloud load balancing I have a managed  instance group with a load balancer in  front of the instances already set up in  my project to turn on cloud CDN and  navigate to networking then I click on  load balancing and click Edit on my load  balancer now I click back into  configuration click on my back-end and  scroll all the way to the bottom and  check the box called enable cloud CDN  now I click update to save the changes  cloud CDN is enabled and cloud load  balancing will cache responses to many  requests at locations all over the world  to find out more about which types of  responses can be cached you can find a  link to the documentation in the video  description I hope you found this cloud  minute helpful